Let's look at one way to
learn those embeddings.
It's called Word2Vec.
Word2Vec is a surprisingly simple
model that works very well.
Imagine you had a corpus of
text with a sentence say,
the quick brown fox
jumps over the lazy dog.
For each word in this sentence,
we're going to map it to an embedding.
Initially a random one.
And then we're going to use
that embedding to try and
predict the context of the word.
In this model, the context is
simply the words that are nearby.
Pick a random word in a window
around the original word,
and that's your target.
Then train your model exactly as
if it were a supervised problem.
The model you're going to use
to predict this nearby word
is a simple logistic regression.
Nothing deep about it,
just a simple linear model.